joining me now former national security
adviser under president uh trump h.r
mcmaster he also has a phd in military
history and he's got a great book out
that talks about this challenge of
ukraine and russia called battlegrounds
to fight to defend the free world hey
general great to see you are you ready
to turn the page are we no longer a
superpower
hey i'm not ready brian and but this is
the narrative that fareed's been on
others have been on for a long time
right this is a this is our tendency
towards self-flagellation right and and
a willingness i think to surrender
leadership on the part of some of our
elites who adhere to some kind of a is
sort of a cosmopolitanism right based on
the belief that what's going to emerge
in the world is some kind of a
condom we can work through the the un
and international organizations well
what you're seeing and all of that's
nonsense right what what really is
important uh or are
really relationships between countries
that share our our values and our and
our principles and that actually have
the power and the will to work together
right to prevent conflict to respond to
the kind of crisis we see in ukraine and
so i think far from it being over i
think what you see now is is that united
states leadership is more important to
the world than ever
and i think people are recognizing that
i don't mind if europe takes the lead if
we make that decision but i hate to
think europe takes the lead because we
left a vacuum and uh general
right now and you you disabuse me of
this thought i think this is historic
moment to remove a cancer that's been
with us for 20 years we don't have a
russia problem it seems to be a putin
problem tell me what we need to make
sure the ukrainians prevail what do we
need to do right
right well you know you just said it
right we have to make sure that russia
fails that ukraine is victorious i think
the other thing that we have to be able
to do is obviously continue to mitigate
this humanitarian crisis but as you're
mentioning right i mean
there's an opportunity you know thanks
to the to the courage and the sacrifice
and the resilience of the ukrainian
people there's an opportunity brian i
think to within cold world war two right
now right and and i think because we're
seeing with a high degree of clarity how
important it is right
generally we were putting the screen
with you
with uh scenes from friday's rally
president putin's rally big crowd big
stadium a lot of pops and circumstance
does that show you that he's still got
power that he still has popularity
hey brian it looks like weakness to me
right and whenever he appears to try to
appear strong it's to mask weakness
right this is the guy who likes to ride
around shirtless on on horseback right
and uh and to film himself you know in
in uh you know in judo sessions and so
forth you know it's bravado uh but i
think what's going to happen brian here
is the the cost of his ineptitude right
of his poor strategic decisions of
making all the wrong assumptions about
ukraine it's going to come back to hurt
him badly you know
you we've seen the you know the numbers
of casualties that have been inflicted
on the russian forces you know he's in
the past tried his best to hide
casualties back in 2014 back when we
clashed with russian mercenaries in
syria and killed hundreds of them they
tried to hide those killed in action so
it it's hard to predict brian but you
know whenever he portrays strength like
that like at that rally i think it
actually betrays profound weakness
general i don't know if this would have
been done if you were the national
security adviser but at the same time
we're trying to support ukraine's win
ago or sustaining
stopping russia from winning in ukraine
there's a deal to be revitalized the
2015 iranian
jcpoa
and we don't know any details but we
know russia is representing us with iran
what's going to be the outcome here and
do we have to live with it
you know i mean the outcome will be
disastrous if we re-enter the iran
nuclear deal under these conditions with
russia as the guarantor of the agreement
really and then and then of course you
know what this is going to do and you're
already starting to see the payoffs
being made to the iranians uh is that
it's just going to give them more
resources to intensify their
four-decade-long proxy war against us
and and you played you know the clip
from fareed and he's talking about the
lack of support from the emiratis and
the saudis hey the reason for that is we
look weak we're supplicating to the
iranians we we took away the designation
of the houthis who are in in yemen uh
not only you know inflicting horrible uh
losses on on on the yemenis people but
they're also using drones and and
missiles to attack the emiratis and the
saudis and we're we're doing nothing
about that right we won't designate them
a terrorist organization they're an
iranian proxy force because we don't
want to
hurt the feelings of the iranians right
so i think you know this this really
makes no sense uh this isn't the end of
american power as fareed said it just is
evidence of a really idiotic policy
toward the iranians based again on a
flawed assumption right that
iran if we welcome them back into the
order they'll moderate their behavior
and we forget to consider not only the
record of this four-decade-long proxy
war against the united states israel
their arab neighbors but the ideology of
the revolution they really believe in
the ideology of the revolution and they
are a government that is hostile to the
to the united states
generally they're not saying we're not
powerful they're saying we don't agree
with your choice of iran over us
uh over uae over oman all these uh all
the
uh the countries that were signing up
for the abraham accords who honestly
could see that israel was not their
problem that iran was so it's the
undoing the success uh because maybe
perhaps donald trump was a part of it
and maybe because you were a part of it
and everybody else they just want to
have their own signature on this and
it's blowing up the middle east and the
eastern europe hopefully we'll have good
resolve on both
general thanks so much hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else